c'est une déclaration qui représente un
grand pas dans un dossier ouvert depuis
sept ans grâce au travail acharné des
deux parties nous avons continué à
réaliser des progrès importants lors des
dernières négociations et l'avenir est
très prometteur
nous espérons que cet accord pourra se
concrétiser rapidement car il va fournir
un cadre général garantissant la
coopération commerciale entre la chine
et l'ue eux et offrir de réels avantages
aux entreprises et aux citoyens des deux
partis proches d'un compromis sur la
protection réciproque de leurs
investissements la chine et les 27 états
membres de l'union européenne semble
enfin s'être mis d'accord après que
pékin aurait accepté de revoir sa
position sur le travail forcé d'après
les sources diplomatiques
mais de quoi s'agit-il concrètement
c'est un texte visant à garantir les
conditions d'activité les entrepreneurs
lorsqu'ils investissent en europe ou en
chine
à noter qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un accord
de libre échange sur les transactions
commerciales
quel effet dans l'avenir des effets
considérables
l'union européenne et la chine sont l'un
pour l'autre les partenaires commerciaux
les plus importants
chacun devant les états unis quand le
stock d'investissements de l'union
européenne vers la chine s'élève à 150
milliards d'euros celui de l'état
chinois vers l'union européenne atteint
113 milliards d'euros quel intérêt pour
l'union européenne
l'intérêt est de protéger les
entreprises européennes implantées en
chine
le texte est censé garantir le respect
de la propriété intellectuelle des
entreprises européennes
interdire les transferts de technologie
forcé et imposer des règles de
transparence sur les subventions versées
aux entreprises publiques chinoises
bruxelles souhaite aussi je cite que la
chine un signe l'ensemble des huit
conventions fondamentales de
l'organisation internationale du travail
pour l'heure pékin n'en a ratifié que
quatre quel intérêt pour la chine
depuis que le groupe chinois huawei a
été exclu du marché des équipements pour
la 5g dans de nombreux pays d'europe
pékin veut des garanties d'accès aux
marchés publics européens
et maintenant si la chine valider cet
accord le parlement européen devra
également le ratifier or quelques points
de discorde existe toujours entre les
deux géants économiques
le dernier en date la demande de
libération immédiate formulées par
l'union européennes de la journaliste
citoyenne than condamné ce lundi à
quatre ans de prison pour avoir diffusé
des vidéos sur wii one la ville qui a
été l'épicentre de la pandémie due
coronavirus reste à savoir quel effet
aura cette nouvelle controverse sur les
discussions en cours entre la chine et
l'union européenne